[Música]
en un mundo que va cada vez más rápido
la palabra compromiso
nos puede dar miedo
porque queremos cambios
y los queremos ya porque
porque hacer lo mismo al resto de
nuestras vidas nos puede parecer
aburrido
pero te has pensado a imaginar
en comprometerte con tus sueños
en comprometerte con algo que te gusta
en comprometerte con algo que te
emociona
que ser maravillosos will y yo nos
comprometimos en una cosa concreta nos
comprometimos en ayudar
unirnos para conseguir un fin compasión
echarnos una mano arrimar el hombro
cuando era un niño tenía un sueño muy
original
quería ser futbolista
porque me encantaba jugar al fútbol a
todas horas
unos de mis mejores recuerdos de la
infancia
yo también tenía un sueño estaba en otro
lugar lejos de wilt mi sueño de pequeña
era tener una casa muy grande donde
acoger a todos los niños en todas las
niñas que necesitarán ayuda
fui creciendo y mi primera parada fue ir
a vietnam a buscar a mi pequeña hija
y ahí comenzó mi historia
y ya en mi segunda parada aterricé en el
continente africano nuestro continente
amigos
y allí ocurrían muchas historias grandes
historias una va a empezar ahora
hoy os quiero contar la historia de mi
vida
cuando tenía cinco años
bien y mayo en marcharse en busca de una
vida mejor
pero yo no lo sabía
y que trabajaría diez años en volver a
verla
mi madre era una madre joven
y soltera que hizo todo lo que pudo para
cuidar de mí pero
llega un momento de mi vida en el que no
pudo hacerse cargo de mí
entonces
desde los 5 a los 17 años
estuve viviendo
con unos familiares
un año con este
otro año con esto y así es como fui
creciendo
cuando éramos niños éramos muy pobres y
ya tenía un negocio pequeño negocio la
venta de ropa usada mi primo y yo íbamos
cada mañana a la calle a vender claro
pausado para intentar ayudar a mi tía en
casa y cuando veíamos a un amigo nuestro
venir de lejos nos escondíamos porque
éramos pobres
pero no digo pobre de mí eso me formó
como persona
pero lorea va
y bueno
aún así era un niño muy alegre
a pesar de todo eso
mientras
estaba en otro lugar
mi trabajo
existe
en logística
acciones
pero se vuelve excepcional por una
cuestión
porque en él
la intención de muchas personas de otras
personas que tenemos otros sueños y esa
intención es conseguir proyectos para
ayudar a personas que están lejos
personas que pueden estar cerca
personas que en muchas ocasiones somos
su única y última esperanza
este es el momento
de mi vida que más me marcó
me acuerdo que me tocó
en algún momento y vive con mi abuela
era un verano y ella sabía que me
encantaba jugar al fútbol
y precisamente ese día me prohibió ir a
jugar
y ya sabéis cómo son los niños cuando
les dices no hagas esto
me escape y fui a jugar
justo antes de
terminaré ese partido he hecho que con
el portero y me lesioné gravemente en la
rodilla
tenía los ligamentos cruzados rotos
la rótula ha salido del sitio
y bueno necesitaba ya una operación
aparte de que mi familia no tenía
suficientes medios realmente tampoco
había una asistencia américa que se
ocupase de ese tipo de lesiones graves
y bueno como yo hay miles de niños
que jamás tienen la posibilidad de tener
una asistencia médica
y es por eso estoy aquí hoy porque me
comprometí conmigo mismo
en ayudar a cambiar la vida de otros
señor para que no pase en la misma
experiencia que pase yo
y ahí nos conocimos will con su ilusión
yo con mi trabajo
con una meta con un compromiso que era
ayudar
personas completamente diferentes
enlazamos nuestros sueños juntos por un
mismo proyecto
convergen nuestros sueños
y aquí comienza nuestro compromiso
de ayuda
la ilusión
después de vivir esa experiencia
donde estuve siete meses sin asistencia
médica
donde básicamente la forma de tratarme
tradicionalmente era que cuatro personas
le ponían contra el suelo
mientras unam estiraba la pierna para
intentar colocar la rodilla y la rótula
en su sitio todo eso sin anestesia y con
tan sólo 11 años
esa experiencia de dolor durante ese
tiempo
me hace de coral que morir en algún
momento
y eso es lo que me hace
pero existir con mi propósito
para cumplir
ese compromiso
que yo es lo que yo quiero cambiar
pero
es fácil hacerlo posible
pues unidos al sueño the wild
de un niño de un pequeño en guinea se
unió el proyecto con la asistencia de
ayudar con asistencia sanitaria nuestro
propósito por contribuir a un mundo
mejor
y compromiso perseverancia
todo eso
para qué
estoy harto estoy entendiendo que en la
vida la gente no compra lo que tú haces
la gente compra en el por qué lo hace
y eso
es lo que demuestra que cada persona de
los que estamos aquí en esta sala se
siente plenamente feliz cuando ayuda a
otras personas sabiendo el por qué lo
hace
entonces es posible hacerlo
posible pues si es posible hacerlo
conseguirlo comenzamos a trazar nuestro
camino william organizamos equipo médico
rumbo a guinea ecuatorial país natal de
guild
tres cirujanos un anestesista dos
enfermeros aterrizamos para dar
asistencia sanitaria a esos niños que lo
necesitaban
nuestra primera expedición 15 días
comenzamos a cosechar grandes historias
historias con dolencias muy parecidas a
las que podría estar padeciendo padeció
huir en su momento pero esta vez con un
final diferente
una moneda de cambio inusual la sonrisa
de un niño y una madre que te da las
gracias en silencio con una mirada
aquí comienzan muchas historias aquí
tenemos a un pequeño al pequeño roberto
está en la foto superior de la derecha
eso es un niño que con un año se quemó y
su cuerpo se pegó lo operamos con tres
años
los los separamos de su cuerpo se hizo
lo que correspondía médicamente y cuando
lo estábamos curando en ese instante
ese niño que llegó así pegado dos años
después de ese accidente no recordaba
cómo era su cuerpo movimiento
y según le quitábamos la gaza hizo así
nos miró miró su mano hizo así
nos mira nos sonríe y con santa paz dice
se mueve
pues ahí es donde está el impulso por
hacer las cosas posibles con esa
historia hay muchas más historias que
gracias al apoyo de wil al compromiso de
wil al compromiso de otras instituciones
pues se van haciendo posibles
lo que me mantiene motivado es pensar
que puedo cambiar un millón de vidas de
otros niños y niñas
que lo necesitan
y para eso que crearon una marca de
europa deportiva
algo que me ayude a conseguir ese
propósito
y que aun aun cuando yo ya no esté vivo
sigue siga haciendo esa función de
mejorar las vidas
hay momentos en esta historia que
estamos contando durante este tiempo
pasan muchas cosas cosas agradables
cosas satisfactorias
tenemos la oportunidad tengo he tenido
la oportunidad de estar presente en
primera línea de acción
nuestro país amigos como el genial
ecuatorial
viendo y a veces viviendo situaciones
muy complejas vas con lo imprescindible
en muchas situaciones casi no es tenían
ni siquiera lo necesario con tu suerte y
la que se te presente en ese momento
lejos de tu familia y a veces te paras y
dices para qué
porque hacemos esto porque estamos aquí
en ese instante
comienza una sonrisa de un niño una
gratitud
un padre que se te acerca y ve como
puede volver a andar como pueden volver
a ver
y ahí en ese momento se despierta en
esos ojos que están dormidos esa sonrisa
que está apagada y con el firme
convencimiento que no es suficiente hay
que continuar tenemos que continuar
y así es cómo
van llegando al final
nuestras historias
dos personas
con dos historias diferentes
pero con el mismo objetivo con el mismo
propósito
ella lo ha dicho
ver la cara de un niño
cuando le han separado en la mano en el
cuerpo
y que te sonría
eso no tiene precio
eso es lo que me hace levantar cada
mañana
pues hemos crecido en mundos distintos
hemos crecido con vidas completamente
diferentes con un objetivo común
y hemos descubierto aunque
comprometiéndonos se puede conseguir un
mundo mejor
ayudar y sentir esta pasión es
fantástico es maravilloso con nuestras
historias queremos despertar en todos la
pasión por ayudar por conseguir un sueño
y sólo nos queda nuestro último mensaje
ay qué apasionarse hay que ayudar si
ganas
muchas gracias muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
no
[Música]